We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two. David P.. Here's an interesting
question about a word I've been using lately.
Take a listen.
Hi, David. This is Mike from Washington State.
I was wondering if you could answer a question
for me. I hear you occasionally refer to Trump
supporters as sick of fans or sycophants.
I'm not really sure what that means or what
the I or what it means, but I don't really
know what you're seeing.
Is that sick of fans or no sector fans or.
You know, I'm not really sure what that term
is. Being said there, so you can clear that
up for me, pursuit of Procurator.
OK. So the term is sycophant. OK, it's s why.
Seo P.H. a. a.. A sycophant is someone who
acts obsequiously towards someone important
in order to gain advantage or gain perceived
advantage. What is obsequious, mean, obsequious,
obsequious is to be obedient or attentive
to an excessive or servile degree. So when
we talk about Trump sycophants, we're talking
about the people who will go with anything,
Trump says. Trump says I deserve a third term
because my first one, I had to deal with impeachment.
They go with it. They are completely non discriminating
in terms of what they will agree with Trump
on. And they do it in order to gain some perceived
advantage. Either it's we want Trump to like
us or it's to be part of the in crowd or it's
because what our family and friends expect
us to do or whatever the case may be. So the
word is sycophant. And often I like to sort
of dress it up by calling them brownnosing
sic offense, but maybe that's a topic for
another day. We've got a great bonus show
for you today. Donald Trump is now lashing
out at New Zealand's coronavirus response
on a day when New Zealand had nine Corona
virus cases. We're going to talk about New
Zealand because it's very interesting what's
going on there. We also have reported 130
degree temperatures in Death Valley, potentially
record temperatures coming in Death Valley.
And in California, more than three million
homes could lose power. I will tell you why
and what's going on. And we'll talk about
energy, solar and much, much more. We've got
a great bonus show coming up for you today.
Get instant access to it two ways.
Become a member.
Join Pacman dot com or become a patron at
Patrick ENCOM slash David Pakman show. I'll
see you then.